monsieur musique la parole et à monsieur
françois de mazières
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre la
situation financière dans nos communes
dans nos départements est plus
qu'alarmante déjà plusieurs départements
ont fait savoir qu'ils n'avaient d'autre
choix que d'augmenter leur fiscalité et
de baisser leurs subventions commune
contrairement à ce que vous avez affirmé
dans cet hémicycle l'effort demandé aux
collectivités locales n'est pas égal
mais nettement supérieur à celui que
s'imposer tant il suffit de se référer
au rapport économique social et
financier annexé au projet de loi de
finances
réac sans l'investissement public
s'effondrent - 25% d'ici 2017
les entreprises du bâtiment sont obligés
licencié en mai 2014
vous avez promis que la réforme
territoriale allait permettre de
réaliser entre 12 et 25 milliards
d'euros d'économies par an où sont ils
vous avez affirmé dans cet hémicycle que
la création des nouvelles régions
générerait plusieurs millions
d'économies mais selon un rapport des
corps d'inspection de l'état que vous
avez bien mis sous le boisseau
ce serait plutôt un surcoût de 250
millions pour faciliter la mobilité des
fonctionnaires
monsieur le premier ministre il ne faut
pas mentir à la représentation nationale
donnez-nous aujourd'hui les vrais
chiffres
comment comprendre que votre majorité
est censuré le rapport de notre collègue
sangsues sur l'impact des baisses de
dotations décembre dernier avez vous
quelque chose à cacher ce rapport dressé
un constat pour nous permettre pour vous
permettre de prendre la mesure des
conséquences le terrain et d'opérer les
ja justement indispensable aussi mes
questions sont les suivantes qu'en
feriez-vous la lumière sur les faits
réels des baisses de dotations sur les
collectivités territoriales
allez-vous revoir les baisses annoncées
pour 2017
allez vous remettre à plat derrière
madame marylise lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et la fonction
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député hier soir devant la commission
des finances du sénat je crois très vite
comme je lai formule est monsieur
carette devant la commission des
finances de votre assemblée nous je
propose qu'on met justement à plat
l'ensemble des chiffres c'est
extrêmement important
il ya de fortes disparités entre les
territoires un des premiers moyens de
répondre à cette forte disparité est à
cette inégalité violente entre le
territoire et sans doute de progresser
en terme d'intercommunalité
nous en sommes d'accord puisque vous
nous avez accompagné sur cette option là
à 2,1 fort moyen également de lutter
contre les disparités
c'est de mutualiser les moyens pour
avoir de meilleurs services avec les
régions vous savez que toutes les
régions autant augmenter leur pib
est ce que vous dites sur les dépenses
concernant le personnel n'est pas tout à
fait juste puisque nous avons tenu dans
la loi à faire un certain nombre de
propositions dont un étalement sur sept
ans en tout des différents alignement
des régimes indemnitaires
je vous propose donc de mettre de faire
un à plein avec vous de l'ensemble des
chiffres de constater qu'effectivement
il ya des communes qui se porte mieux
que d'autres et pour répondre à cette
question j'ai prenons j'ai proposé
pardon au nom du gouvernement une
révision de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement parce que personne ne
peut lire actuellement quels sont les
critères de répartition
il nous faut des critères clairs des
critères justes la ruralité la
centralité par exemple et je suis à
votre disposition
chiffres en main pour discuter avec vous
devant la commission des finances
merci madame la ministre la parole